Michael Wilbon a pardon the interruption
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Michael
rich I'm good how are you I'm doing
better for talking to you
where'd you watch the Big Ten
championship game how'd that go down in
the from the about the 5-yard line
with you in there have you outlined he
is of course of course listen but not
like you know Michigan alums who think
the team is going to these games every
year you think I'm gonna miss the only
time in history northwestern is banned a
short history
northwestern's been to a big tent I
don't care come on now mm-hmm man I love
your coach I love him I love Pat
Fitzgerald and those guys that he
recruits in the way that they play I
love it I really do I do rich you know
look we played I don't know probably uh
eight on a one to ten level assisting we
were down 24 21 and I think it was 31 24
and we had at the ball down each time
and a chance to tie or take the lead and
you know we needed Ohio State to play in
about a level or five like we saw them
they were lower than that against
Maryland
you know Purdue we needed that and we
didn't get that and you know was a
competitive game and I'm thrilled it was
but Ohio State's a better team now and
but yeah you bet your fat Fitzgerald and
those kids I mean lately I mean over the
past four years if you check the wins
and losses the only way I care to
measure these things I'm gonna say we're
probably fourth in the big ten behind
the obvious three and whatever ordered I
guess gotta be Ohio State Ohio State
Penn State Michigan or Michigan Penn
State after that I'm gonna say it's us
right there with Michigan State and
Wisconsin with that you know we've got
to 10-win seasons in the last three so
ya know it's gonna watch that from
television that's gonna be that's gonna
be front setter okay so you watched you
eyeballed personally the Ohio State do
you think that the college football
playoff committee got it right
you know rich they got it fine I'm not
sure they got it right I don't think
there's a right and wrong but I got it's
just fine I don't want to hear the
whining from Georgia you know you're an
equal footing you playing the same
conferences Alabama you recruit the same
kids as Alabama you got a coach we know
is a terrific coach who learned it's the
knee one of the people he did was from
the coach at Alabama and kerby's Martin
hey I don't want to hear from them
blowing a two-touchdown lead in the
fourth quarter did somehow everybody got
it wrong if they put in Oklahoma or Ohio
State don't want to hear it George has
had its chances I mean just you know
what they could be penalized and passed
over for the for the fake punt alone you
know you make those decisions and you
lose that game after having a lead on a
neutral site I don't hear it so so
Oklahoma in the title game is in them in
the final force fine for me
Ohio State would have been fine Georgia
would have been fine any of those three
teams you can you can split hairs if you
want but I don't want to hear from
Georgia that somehow they were wrong
good I was saying that the Jalen hurts
comeback if you will story
the only thing comparing I could compare
it to is Drew Bledsoe coming back for
the injured Tom Brady to win the 2001
AFC championship game and put the
Patriots in the Super Bowl that's the
only thing I could compare it to what
what is your take on on hurts and and
that story in Alabama that unfolded in
the SEC championship game Michael you
know that's a great poll just to think
of that I did not think of that
um but I think the hurt story is even
more I don't know I don't want to get
carried away here and say inspirational
but it's certainly a cautionary tale
it's a wonderful story in that the
husband's a kid I mean that paid to play
football like Grady and Bledsoe
I mean this is a Tuesday there could
have transferred out who had to trust a
lot of people including a coaching staff
and you know you don't always have to
trust the coaches that we know plenty of
tales of kids transferring because they
didn't trust the coaching staff so it's
probably and this is very clichéd of
credit to everybody involved the
coaching staff at Alabama his parents
the teammates friends but
of all Jalen Hurd's who has never done
anything but uttered the right thing
when asked about this it must have been
terribly difficult at times to be 26 and
2 and told you're being replaced and to
get this chance and I don't know what
happens from here it doesn't much matter
to me as much that Jalen Hurd's has
cemented his place in these great sports
stories it's just you know what it's
just basic just aim it must be a hell of
a kid to be able to do this and pull
this off and then not just getting the
chance of taking advantage of it and
playing as well as he did even in the
area in which it was thought he at a
shortcoming the passing game in looking
at any shortcomings on Saturday night
when I was watching so good for him man
I think it's pretty uncomfortable so who
do you vote for Heisman right now
Michael Wow
you know two up tool was great for a
longer stretch and three weeks ago I
thought it was gonna be like you know
Steph Curry in that unanimous MVP award
it's not gonna be that now you know I've
I have a ten year old who all he does is
watch college football just fall in love
with college football he just consumes
it like a madman like he was somebody's
scout and he turned him he's been saying
Kyler Murray for two weeks and as soon
as Kyler Murray finished off you know
his game the other night against Texas
my son
the smarter like turns to me were
sitting in a box in Indianapolis he
turns to me and says dad I told you
calimary and for the first time I
couldn't just say shut up you're wrong I
didn't I didn't have that ace up my
sleeve
I used to vote rich I voted for twenty
years
I don't vote anymore but if I had a
ballot I think I would go to her but I
was this is one of those ones where I
would have called scouts and coaches
assistant people I know who make a
living in college football I would have
called them and relied heavily on what
they thought because I no longer can
make up my mind necklace yeah well you
know now I I do I've never had a vote
would I'd take one if offered but you
know what the way and again I might be
biased cuz you you you covet what you
see a kid Dwayne Haskins man to it
didn't even play to it in plate cuz you
could sit here and say well Ohio State
was up and down but to hardly played a
fourth quarter and I know what Carla
Murray's dump but Haskins right in front
of you that night what he did against
Michigan what he's been doing against
you know Maryland when the defense
couldn't stop anybody and that and that
and that's a pressure game for him
because that's his that's his hometown I
mean that was the team that he you know
initially who everybody thought was
gonna go play for I mean his last three
weeks have been incredible he's closed
out big time Michael you know you have
to came on you right he's been on the
rail he came late I like you know I
watched the big ten if I'm not watching
anything else I'm watching my conference
and I I just thought okay well he's you
know he's third and then there's no way
but you know what's the other night it
sort of went quietly he threw for four
hundred ninety nine yards you know hi Oh
state needed to keep scoring because we
had scored enough I mean we needed to
score in the 30s and we couldn't because
Haskins stayed on the field and
dominated the ball and there their clock
does their clock dominance in ball
possession was as a result rich of their
passing game I mean he did was a passing
game with you know veteran you know old
school coaches seek to do with a running
game and you're right he's I mean I
gotten to see you know too much of a
eyeful of him but I still I think I
would vote to a Murray and Haskins I
think I would but again if I was doing
this you know college football for a
living like I did for a long time sure I
mean I would sit and I would be open to
convincing to persuasion because those
three kids have been absolutely fabulous
and still one thing to has done is he's
done it all season and he's done it
where they're beating people by margins
that teams just don't win by
consistently anymore Michael Wilbon a
pardon the interruption a few more
minutes left with him okay a couple
Chicago questions Michael first one
football all right here we go
Lyons
to the Rams at home the Packers lose to
the Cardinals at home and Mike McCarthy
fired the Vikings with their a four
million dollar man going to New England
and they weren't they were in the game
but they couldn't pull it off and the
Bears were their backup quarterback come
back from ten down there and almost
pulled it off and so far in front of
this division how does it feel to not
only be set up in the short term but
what the way this team looks like it's
built long-term atop that division as it
bears came out of nowhere and and you
know for a while I mean I was certainly
critical of the knew of the relatively
new GM Ryan pace I guess it's like four
years now because there were draft picks
like taking the kids from the wide
receiver from from West Virginia who he
can't even get on the field just been a
bust and they traded a lot to get your
Biscay when he was really unknown but it
is all he is proven to be right Ryan
faced a few critics like me it for me to
be wrong so far but you know what rich
they give up the Bears give away a game
yesterday I mean for people who just
started paying attention to that game
late when they come back they should
have been behind like that and you know
what I don't want to be critical of a
backup quarterback who wins in Detroit
on Thanksgiving Day which is what Jake's
Daniel did a week ago but you know he
came out in his Jay Cutler costume and
threw a pick six to start the game and
they were just behind and you mentioned
those other teams losing the Bears were
the team yesterday that stood to just
really put it on lock you know if they
had won that game I'm not saying about
coming back to win it they were leading
14-7 and they weren't controlling the
game and made some mistakes and one of
them belongs to the head coach for
calling the timeout
and allowing the Giants to develop some
momentum out of nowhere at halftime
which he did he took he took
responsibility for that yesterday
postgame and I was glad about that but
you know look they are so much better
than we thought in the trade for Khalil
Mack going back to crediting Ryan pace
the trade for Mack you talk about people
making their teammates better there's
tangible evidence that you you look at
the way they played with him in the
first few games he was hurting missed
two and then they played that way
without him they were like just infused
with the spirit of Mack and it can't be
exaggerated what he's meant to that team
and I'm not saying Aaron
is not as valuable defensively there
other players who are but what the Bears
have done with Mac since that trade it's
been great but they let's I don't want
to go crazy on this you know any given
Sunday so the next two weeks the Bears
need to win one of these next two games
because they've got the Rams at home on
Sunday night in the game that says flex
to prime time they've got Green Bay at
home the next week they need to win one
of those two because their last name
rich if they have to have it if they
have to go into the finale season finale
to win its at Minnesota that's not a
preferable circumstance so that's the
other game that I had mentioned is at
San Francisco
so they got time they need to win this
before they have to go to Minnesota and
win it you don't want to have to do that
so but the Bears have been you know
perhaps the surprise of the season in
many ways and I'm look I'm thrilled but
I don't want to start counting chickens
just yet they that game yesterday which
everybody says always a thrilling
comeback it was also a missed
opportunity they gave away a game in
Miami they gave away of 20 nothing lead
to the Packers week one they got to stop
that if they're gonna cash in on this
ultimately short term or long and last
one for you Michael three-and-a-half
years after being plucked from the
campus of Iowa State
the mayor Fred Hoiberg bounced after a
record of 115 in 155 your thoughts on
the firing in the state of the Bulls in
Chicago yeah I'm surprised by this
because I don't get the point so the
Bulls have had three of their top five
players injured basically until a game
ago I mean a Lorimar cannons been
injured Bobby Portis has been injured
Chris Don the starting point guard has
been injured that's three of their top
five six players I think through this up
I don't that's been out so what's the
Berg's supposed to do and I will let me
say I just applaud the rise or family
and Jerry and Michael are not trying to
have the process they're not trying to
tank and go into the lottery every year
and then sort of raise their hands and
try up and say look what we did they
they're trying to win and so I get that
but when you look at the college pool of
talent there's one guy maybe two that
can change it one guys Iowa and say you
know can change the Bears are
I'm out I think of the worst record in
the NBA I think their five wins and
somebody a couple people have for
Atlanta may have four yep to understand
what's hiring Heiberg at this point does
um and I don't think there's off the
court stuff I mean Fred is what you see
is what you get just seems like a
terrific guy and I could see replacing
him in two years if you didn't think
that you know you got your own personal
roster established and you want to
really go after a playoff spot right I
got it I got to do some delving into
this because to me it just seems like
why are you doing this you can't just
look at the record you're looking at
working with young players and
incredibly young roster you want to get
them better playing well out to the
break and they they're you can't win in
the NBA when you're missing three of
your top five after Golden State
Warriors who've been missing two
all-stars and they've lost 8 of 13 so I
I don't know I'm a little dubious on
this I applaud the Bulls for not wanting
to engage and what I consider largely a
phony thing the process when you can
just Draft after Draft after draft six
years well damn you better get it right
at some point you know it's while
patting yourselves on the back but a
little bit for Fred and I don't you know
I don't exactly know why it timed out
the way it did not yet Mike you're the
best man say hi to mr. Toney for me okay
is it possible is it possible to get you
and Tony to do a tiger versus Phil sort
of golf pay-per-view I'd pay to see that
Michael I think people would only pay to
see that if we started fighting in the
middle of the rats what we're looking
for yeah Mike Mike yeah let's leave
great take care of Michael thanks for
the call boys at micro bond on Twitter
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience